اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من تلي ابيب اهلا
بكم نحو 80 شهيدا في غارات اسرائيليه
استهدفت منازل جنوبي قطاع غزه كتائب
القسام تعلن قصفه لابيب وعسقلان وتؤكد
جاهزيتها لمواجهه اي عمليه بريه اسرائيليه
والجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه يستعد للمرحله
التاليه من الحرب وان الجميع يتحدث عن
عمليه بريه وقد يكون هناك شيء
اخر منظمه الصحه العالميه تدعو اسرائيل
الى الغاء اوامر اجلاء الفلسطينيين من
شمال قطاع غزه الامم المتحده تصف امر
الاجلاء بانه قد يرقى لمستوى النقل القصري
للمدنيين وانتهاك للقانون الدولي والهلال
الاحمر يقول ان سكان القطاع يعانون نقصا
شديدا في الماء والغذاء والدواء
والوقود قائد القياده الوسطى الامريكيه في
تلي ابيب واستعدادات امريكيه لنشر 2000
جندي في المنطقه الكرملين ي يحذر من تحول
الصراع الى حرب اقليميه والمرشد الايراني
يقول انه لا ينبغي لاحد ان يطلب منع فريق
ما من الرد على جرائم الصهاينه في حين شدد
العاهل الاردني على عدم امكانيه استقبال
لاجئين فلسطينيين في الاردن ولا
مصر الجيش الاسرائيلي يقصف عده مواقع في
الجنوب اللبناني ويقول ان القصف رد على
اطلاق نيران من الاراضي اللبنانيه وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه تعلن اصابه عده اشخاص في
قصف على بلده المطلي والجيش الاسرائيلي
يعلن البلده منطقه عسكريه مغلقه ويدعو
سكانها الى مغادرتها الى
اللقاء